hello everyone um welcome to the second
talk of this uh morning session our
speaker uh is going to be Alexander
bakos who works at the Platinum level P
data sponsor Dexter energy um
he and um he will try to convince us to
use probabilistic instead of
deterministic forecasts at least when
trying to predict renewable energy
generation and yesterday I was at um the
booth from Dexter energy and as some of
you may know there's a similar talk
going on right now in the barroom but
the fine folks at Dexter told me that
this talk is way more interesting so
I'm uh I can reassure you that you made
the right decision in coming here so a
big round of applause for for Alexander
bakos
please all right hey welcome thanks for
coming my name is Alexander bakas I'm a
dat science manager at Dexter energy I
will tell more about Dexter energy in a
moment but we'll in this talk we'll be
diving into energy time series
forecasting and then specifically
probabilistic
forecasting but before we do that we'll
first need to understand a bit more
about energy markets and why we need
forecast in the third place and this
story this story starts with climate
change so one of the biggest if not the
biggest challenge of our time global
warming has led to an increase in
extreme weather events natural disasters
and the rising sea levels they pose an
existential threat to humans across the
globe endangering the Earth's entire
ecosystem and the main driver of climate
change is the vast amount of emissions
of greenhouse gases we've put into the
atmosphere over the past
Century the energy sector accounts for
over 73% of these emissions
and of these 73% a significant
proportion is from fossil fueled powered
thermal plants that provide
electricity and also a large proportion
of that that 73% can be replaced with
more renewable sources and therefore to
mitigate climate change one important
strategy that we have is to transition
to a renewable energy
Supply
and this is not only an important
strategy in the battle against climate
change it is also an enabler for our
sustainable growth of our ever
increasing need for
energy and in the recent years we have
seen an accelerated increased
introduction of introduction of
Renewables into the
grid but this comes with a a big
Challenge and this challenge is about
balance in the grids so the energy grid
needs to stay in balance at any moment
in time Supply needs to equal the demand
the energy amount of energy going into
the
system into the grid needs to be the
same as the energy that's
consumed and uh if this doesn't happen
you get a drop in the frequency of the
system and only a small drop in the
frequency or rise just of a quarter
percent off this can already make
devices break and ultimately this can
lead to a blackout
so why is this a problem again well with
the
Renewables keeping this Supply stable is
not so easy so here you see actual wind
and
solar power generation across a span of
four
days on the y axis you see the megawatt
hours and on the XA you see the time in
days and what you see here is that the
supply of these renewable energy sources
is intermittent and also to a large
degree non-steerable so it happens it
comes when it happens when the wind
blows when the sun shines this means
that you have we have to transition from
a more demand driven system to supply
driven system so demand driven it was
because fossil fuel powered thermal
plants they can spin up when the demand
is high but now we are Supply driven we
need to adapt to this generation
pattern because demand is usually not
that
flexible and we want to allow scheduling
of this demand of the consumption to
match the
production and a renewable energy
supplier like here this plate needs to
tell in advance what they think they'll
produce what they'll generate and this
all happens on the energy markets so
this brings me to energy markets on
these markets participants can buy and
sell energy and there are many of these
markets Advanced markets H but I'll
focus on the day ahead you see here a
timeline T minus one one day in advance
at noon renewable energy suppliers but
energy suppliers of any kind need to say
what kind of power volume they think
they'll
generate and then there is t0 which is
time of delivery then whenever you sell
there needs to be delivered at that time
point and we'll see in a moment what
happens if you canle deliver at that
time point so here you see the day had
Market at T minus one say that our
hypothetical renewable energy supplier
sold a volume of 200 megawatt hours for
certain point in the ne on the next day
and this price that the supplier gets
for that is
90 if they would sell a bit less so
instead of 200 we go to 100 then the
supply decreases then the de the price
increases so the good becomes more
scarce the price increases and this is
basically the idea of that the energy
Market tries to mat Supply in the month
mediated by the price so dynamically
setting the the price to match supply
and demand and now this brings me to
what happens when we sold the wrong
quantity on the dead
market so let's in this example say that
we have actually only generated 80
megawatt hours while we sold a 100 well
this actually means we're 20 megawatt
hours short so we have to
basically buy that back on the time of
delivery on the balancing Market we buy
back that energy for 300 Euros a
megawatt hour why is this again so high
now in because everybody has the same
problem everybody might have under
forecasted and under
predicted so everybody short there's a
general shortage on the grid so the
price on the balancing Market goes
up and negative imbalance the system is
short and then there's these imbalance
costs that our hypothetical renewable
energy supplier incurs these are the
difference in power multiplied by the
difference in price so if we take this
example and that's a penalty you get for
basically destabilizing the grid you can
see view it like that so if we plug the
numbers into our example we get a
difference of 20 megawatt hours that we
have short and the difference of €200
per megawatt hours in the difference
between these two markets that they had
in the balancing Market we get a penalty
an imbalance cost of €4,000 for this
only this
instant and this money is going to
someone else usually a fossil fuel power
thermal plant that actually is going to
compensate for this shortage and they
get a reward of
€4,000 for helping balance the grid and
you can imagine that this is
particularly a problem for the renewable
energy supplier because they have this
unpredictable hardto predict
intermittent
Supply and the money from sustainable
energy sources is going to unsustainable
sources and this brings me to
introducing Dexter energy so what we do
is we provide short-term power for
forecast and trade optimization for
renewable portfolios and therefore we
make renewable energy more predictable
and therefore more profitable we're
scalop we're founded in 2016 based in
amdam and we have around 55 people
working at Dexter and we're growing
fast so this is Dexter let's now talk
about the forecast we give and also
related to our example recall the
formula for imbalance
cost so so there are two key unknown
quantities volume and
price and the supplier can leverage
power forecast and Price Forecast to get
an optimal trading strategy so
recommended trade in this picture here
and let's focus now a bit more on price
and this Price Forecast captures
actually the uncertainty that is in the
system we can now going to zoom into how
Price Forecast can help balance the
grid so this is our example from
previous from earlier and we now have
added forecast so let's assume for the
illustrative purposes that these
forecasts are accurate now the question
is so we forecast that we will only
predict or we only produce 80 we only
generate 80 megawatt hours and we also
have Price Forecast now knowing this and
knowing what kind of imbalance cost we
can incur what should we sell on this
dead Market what kind of
volume so I have four options
we sell as much as we can we sell
nothing zero or we sell a bit more or a
bit less show hands who thinks we should
sell as much as we
can nobody who should think we should
sell
nothing yeah I see a couple of hands
yeah this interesting I'll get back to
that we should we who thinks we should
sell a little bit
more little bit more and a bit less who
thinks we should sell a bit I see a lot
of f
now that's good that's that's correct
that's the correct answer so and I will
get to why B is not the correct answer
in a moment because that's pretty
interesting in itself so we sell a bit
less like 5 megawatt hours
less then we're the ones actually having
this kind of surplus at the time of
delivery and we can help balance the
grid and also because of this price
Dynamic price elasticity we actually
lowered the Delta price a bit there's
less grid imbalance and we for that get
a reward of 5 time 100 EUR Euros per
megawatt hour so
500 yeah reward you could
say and why are we not going to hold
everything back so go to zero well
there's two main reasons for that that I
want to highlight now so the first one
is that there's a so-called price maker
effect so if we go down a lot we
also kind of change this price
difference a lot and we might flip the
market Market into an Surplus State
because we have all this left over 80
megawatt hours then there's like hey
there's a surplus on the grid and we
flipped it and that basically means that
we again incur a big penalty actually a
very big one for flipping the market so
this is not good either and the second
reason is that you might want to stare
on your own risk appetite so how much
Financial Risk are you willing to take
in a situation and that also brings you
to not trading going all in but trading
a little bit less
let me explain this so here you see a
point forecast so basically a Time
series of the price some actuals and
then a T minus one we want to predict
the next time series the course of that
so
forecast but we need to harness the
uncertainty in the system learn to
embrace it we forecast percentiles or
quantiles so basically many
different prediction
intervals for each time point point in
the
future and so we get a probability
distribution at each time point in the
future so let me explain that with a
following outline so if we take a slice
here we basically see that there's a a
probability density function as it's
called on each slice so you have the
price on the x-axis and then you see the
amount of probability Mass on the Y
AIS so in this
case we get a probability for each
possible future and if we then look at
this uh probability density function we
see a q80 that means that 80% of the
observations will lie below so we can
use this number to sort of steer on risk
how because if we see this picture we
know we can probably expect a positive
price but if I now show you this one
there's an interesting bodal
distribution here with a a small but
significant probability that we have a
negative price instead so you might want
to do something completely different
depending on what kind of power you
expect to generate or what kind of
financial risks you're willing to take
how much you weigh loss over gains how
do we get this probabalistic
forecast basically we can view it as a
Time serious regression problem where we
take some models from forecasting model
it's can be a machine learning model and
we feeded input features from the market
prices grid data some Auto regressive
features we can build upon that and very
importantly weather data what kind of
weather is it going to be out coverage
Sunshine temperature wind speeds this
kind of
stuff and then remember this price maker
effect that I talk about you also should
actually include your own trading
actions in this model and make some sort
of Cal model that tries to predict the
price given what you will do on the
market this topic is however going very
much into the secret SCE of Dexter and
outside the scope of the talk so I will
focus on leaving this out and taking a
so-called price taker assumption so that
we don't affect the price but we we
model it such that we don't affect the
price which is not true in reality so
how do we get this model to Output a
probabilistic forecast so a probability
density
function as always we should start
simple with a baseline model so we can
take our P Point forecasting model that
we already have and get the residuals on
a calibration data set so we hold out
some data and there we compute our
residual ual and we get error
distribution and then for a new data
point we take the prediction from our
Point forecast model and just simply
overlay that using the point forecast as
a mean for the distribution this is a
very simple Baseline model that already
has couple of nice properties and that
is it is distribution free it can assume
any distribution nonparametrically that
the data has also guarantees that your
quantiles are
correct but it also has a disadvantage
which is that it's the same for every
it's the same for every point that you
predict so there's no
variation and maybe this is a good time
to discuss on what defines a good
probabalistic forecast so there's two
main Concepts I want to cover here the
first one is calibration the second one
is
sharpness calibration is about if we
take the 20 the q20 so the 20th quantal
are also 20% of the observations in some
new test set below that quantum
so if you for that you can plot make a
QQ plot Quant Quant plot where you put
the the theoretical Quant on the xais
that's the quantal we want to to
actually predict against the sampled
quantal that's the quantal you get from
the data on some sort of calibration
data set or whole validation data set
and the perfectly calibrated model
follows the diagonal so the q20 would be
a point on
q20 but here see a model that's not so
well calibrated so actually at q20 it's
more actually more in the neighborhood
of the q40 and this is what we call
coverage error so this is not good you
want to sort of get a straight line
there but the model can be perfectly
calibrated but still not give you a lot
of predictive
information and this Baseline approach
can be very with very broad uncertainty
for each point so therefore you also
want to look at the sharpness basically
this is our probability distribution
function again and this kind of PDF
gives us a different picture than this
kind of
PDF so that's the sharpness and I will
now present a metric that can cover both
which is continuous rank probability
score and we have our PDF here on the
screen we convert that to cumulative
distribution function so we basically
take the cumulative sum so it goes from
zero to one so this transformation is
pretty
important and then we basically take the
area that's between the actual so the
actual is a point on the uh on the xaxis
basically we take this area that is
shaded here in red and that is our
continuous rank probability score and in
the formula we use this heavy side step
function to indicate in which side of
the actual you are and which area you
need to sum and the nice property of
CRPS is is that it captured not only
calibration and sharpness in one go but
also it has
interpretability because it's a
generalization of the mean absolute
error so if now I just take our Point
forecast here ploted in a dotted line in
both the PDF and
CDF then we see that it's basically a
step function and if we then take that
area that red shaded area according to
the formula the CRPS is equal to the
mean absolute error so if we say we're
10 EUR off with CRPS then we know this
probabilistic forecast is on average 10
EUR off that's pretty
handy and now back to our probalistic
forecasting method because we call our
Baseline method gave the same result for
every same uncertainty interval for
every um every
observation I will now outline three
methods to obtain conditional
uncertainty estimates and they all boil
down to quantal
regression uh and this is important
because uncertainty is not always the
same if it's a sunny day you might have
a different uncertainty profile than
when it's a cloudy day and this is
called heteros cessity in statistical
terms but the variance is not the same I
will now yeah go into these three
approaches quanti loss quantile Force
and a quantal binning approach the first
one quantal loss is basically to
asymmetrically weigh the errors of a
model during the training so here you
see a loss function this is basically
the error on the x-axis and the weight
of that error on the Y AIS so in a mean
absolute error or L1
loss we basically have a weight which is
identical to the error so it's
symmetrical and we don't over penalize
over forecast or under
forecast if we now want to estimate for
instance the q20 the 20th quantal we
actually going to overway under
forecasting and therefore the model will
overemphasize the lower part of the so
try to sort of in general get a predict
a lower value than the
median and this is also called pinball
loss why because it kind of resembles
the movement of a pinball
ball you can extend a a model like libm
regressor using this quantum
you say the objective is quanta you
indicate Alpha which is the slope of the
red
lines and then you can have your point
here on your probability distribution
density
function and then if you take the last
example for want to estimate a q30 or
q80 we flip it around we overway over
forecast and by doing that a lot of time
repeating this for different Quant we
can get the full distribution
function second approach is has a
theoretical connection with quantal but
the way to get there is difference is to
aggregate Ensemble predictions we start
with a random Forest here where we take
the training data and we take bootstrap
samples and from these bootstrap
samples we kind of we make decision
trees and if we fully grow these trees
with having one sample per Leaf we
basically can with a test data point we
can just take these individual
predictions and create a histogram or a
density function from that and this is
this is also pretty neat Tri trick um
but in practice you might not want to
fully grow your trees to prevent
overfitting you might have samples with
the same Target value in one Le so a
bunch of problems so you want to make
sure if you implement this that you for
instance store training samples in each
leaf or create histograms and weigh them
properly but this is the basic
concept now for the last quantal
regression approach it's again the same
idea but a different method is is to
reduce so reduction of the quantum
regression problem to classification
problem how does this work well first we
bin our Target so our price that we want
to predict into intervals so we say does
the price lie between zero and 10
between 10 and 20 between 20 and 30 for
each sample in our trading data we
encode it in a one H
encoding as I've done here on the screen
then we train a model this can be any
multiclass classifier that's where of
this the probability some to one so one
trick is you can wrap any classifier in
one versus rest and then from pyed learn
and then you can basically use anything
you want then at the prediction
time you simply take the probabilities
for each of these bins and construct a
histogram and then a probability density
function from that so an example here
you see that these probabilities they
match up to the um yeah to the his to
the
histogram
disadvantage of this method is that it
can produce very noisy PDF in particular
when there's areas in the feature space
where there is a low amount of samples
this is a common problem and it is
remains key to really assess the quality
of your probalistic forecast in a
rigorous
way so one of the last topics I want to
touch upon is that a big problem of all
the approach that we discussed is that
although in theory they should give a
well calibrated prediction they in
practice they don't all kinds of reasons
overfitting and noise in the data and we
would actually like to have these
theoretical guarantees so that if we
take for instance the 40th quanti that
only 40% of the observations lies below
that and not more not less if we don't
have that well calibration right
calibration we might make a wrong trade
decision and then destabilize the gridge
that's not what we want and one
framework that has gained increased in
popularity is conformal
prediction and I will now outline what
that is in the basic form we can apply
it to our Quant regression as an ad hook
postprocessing we take our quantal
regression model for instance for the
q40 we have a model trained with quantal
loss this is our Quant 40 40 quanta
model and then on a calibration data set
again we hold this out we don't train on
that we predict make predictions and
again we extract the error distributions
and then we look where is our sample
quantal and what is the actual quantal
in the error distribution so in this
case you see that the sample quantal are
the the number of of observations with a
lower value are around
20% this is not good so we want to shift
it a bit to the um to the right and um
uh that's a correction factor and we
basically add this correction factor to
the original quantal prediction to
ensure coverage
and this giv those well calibrated
predictions with mild assumptions so
again distribution free there's one
critical assumption though which is the
exchangeability assumption is that and
that's tricky with time series because
yeah you if you have a non-stationary
Time series the um the samples are not
independent and identically distributed
random variables so you want to make
sure that you would do it some sort of a
rolling window kind of fashion there's a
a package uh it's called maybe that that
has this kind of logic implemented it's
an an area of active resource research
um I invite you to um to check out the
the resources and uh learn more about it
it's very
exciting okay this brings me to the last
point is that we talked about the price
forecasting but how do we combine it
with power forecasting well this can
also be a probalistic forecast so you
have two probability distributions for
any prediction you can plug that into an
optimization engine this can be in the
simplest form of Monte Carlo simulation
where you compute for each sample that
you draw and then you combine them you
compute the cost using the formula we we
actually
explained and this is a very simple
approach uh there are more intricacies
to this problem than I can explain in
the in in the time that I have here and
there's also different impro approaches
here I really recommend the work of uh
Pierre Pinon here reference in the in
the corner of the slide if you're
interested in learning more about this
topic
this brings me to the key takeaways from
this talk first I hope I shown you how
probabalistic forecasting can add value
by enabling risk-based energy trading So
based on your risk appetite your loss
versus gains you can make different
decisions and help stabilize the
grid how existing machine learning
models can be extended to estimate
quantal shown three four three
approaches plus a baseline
approach and finally lastly I hope to
have shown that probabilistic
forecasting can help accelerate the
energy transition to renewable energy
sources and with that I'd like to end
thanks for your attention and I'm happy
to take a couple of
questions